[Music]
if you've ever looked at the bottom of a
disposable bottle or cup you've probably
noticed this symbol seeing this many
people assume the item they're holding
should be tossed in a recycling bin yet
many of these Plastics are incapable of
being recycled at most centers in fact
of the 360 million tons of plastic
created world wide each year only 9% is
ever recycled so why are so few Plastics
recycled and what do these codes
actually mean our recycling problem is
multi-layered beginning at production
about 18% of plastics are made from what
is known as thermos setting polymers
these Plastics gain stability through
curing a process that hardens the
material by irreversibly cross-linking
its molecular chains the very properties
that make Theros set Plastics so useful
in that they keep their shape and
integrity under extreme conditions mean
that they can't be broken down and
rebuilt by the vast majority of
recycling plants thankfully most
Plastics are thermoplastics which can be
melted and
remolded but this category encompasses a
variety of materials with unique
chemical structures weights and
properties all of which require
different
conditions for recycling as a result
only some of these thermoplastics are
accepted at most recycling centers which
brings us to our next problem the
confusing Code
system developed and introduced by the
Plastics industry in
1988 this code was presented as a way to
help consumers and Facilities sort their
trash each number indicates the material
the plastic is made of known as its
resin some resin number numbers are
recyclable at most centers While others
are not and yet within this system all
numbers are surrounded by the
universally recognized recycling symbol
misleading consumers into thinking that
many unsalvageable Plastics have a
chance at a second life and just because
a technically recyclable resin makes it
to a recycling B doesn't mean it will
continue its Journey Plastics often
contain multiple resins are mixed with
dyes and additives or are affixed with
difficult to remove stickers and labels
all of which can cause them to be
rerouted to the incinerator or trash bin
in short many companies don't design
packaging with recovery in mind even
under pristine conditions plastic resins
can only be melted down and remolded a
handful of times as their polymers
degrade with each use if all these
issues make you feel as if recycling
Plastics is infeasible you wouldn't be
the first this reality was well known to
the Plastics industry as early as the
1970s despite their doubts that
widespread recycling would ever be
economically viable the industry threw
millions of dollars into ad campaigns
within the US the Plastics industry
quietly lobbied state governments
leading a majority to adopt laws
requiring that Plastics bear the
confusing resin code
and with this the burden of fixing the
growing plastic waste problem was pushed
from the industry onto the
consumer today the situation has only
gotten worse the rising costs to
properly separate all this waste paired
with fewer international buyers of
recyclable scraps has forced many cities
to shut down their curbside recycling
programs
altogether so how can we fix our growing
plastic waste
system it's clear that we must reduce
the Plastics we consume more than a
quarter of our plastic waste comes from
packaging materials many manufacturers
have taken steps in the right direction
phasing out unnecessary plastic films
and switching out plastic tubs and tubes
with more easily recyclable materials or
compostable options for the Plastics
that do remain one solution is to work
towards a circular economy for Plastics
this means creating fewer new Plastics
eliminating those that are single use
and ensuring the Plastics that remain
can stay in circulation via recycling
such a system would rely on policies
that regulate Plastics starting at their
production ensuring that all Plastics
created are free from contaminants that
could harm their ability to be
recycled in the meantime many experts
believe the current resin Code system
should be eliminated ated and swapped
out for Clear simplified recyclable
versus non-recyclable labels this would
help consumers more easily sort their
waste but more importantly allow them to
make informed decisions at purchase
ultimately putting the pressure back on
manufacturers to ensure a recyclable
[Music]
future did you know a dead battery is
actually not that different from a fresh
one learn what makes batteries uniquely
reused ible with this video or visit
ed.ted.com
earthschool to check out our climate
action guide no matter your level of
influence you have a part to play in
protecting our
planet